I was five and he was six we rode on
horses made of sticks he were black and
I were white he would always win the
fight bang bang he shot me down bang
bang I hit the ground bang bang many
young men dream of sitting behind the
wheel of a powerful sports car with a
pretty young thing in the passenger seat
but joy bunch has stepped out of the
dream dispensed with the man and gotten
into the driver's seat of her own 1969
chevrolet corvette
still Joey was inspired by a very
special man her father
haha she explains that her father
started driving triumph tr5 s in 1978
and she grew up in sports cars riding
shotgun with her dad until she moved out
as a little girl she either sat on the
jump seats and back or behind the
parking brake with one leg in her dad's
foot well and the other leg and her
mom's they always took the old sports
car on vacation and in the end she
developed her own passion for vintage
cars though her father died before his
time he passed on his love for vintage
cars to his daughter when she was just
19 Joey fell in love with a third
generation Chevrolet Corvette a year
later she took the chance and made it
her own the Corvette c3 was modeled on
to the Makos shark concept car it was
built for nearly 50 years with only
minor changes
concealed headlamps round recessed tail
lights and wide tires were the cars
trademarks at like all Corvettes it had
a fiberglass body with heavy metal under
the hood
Joey says the flared contours along the
sides and futuristic design don't really
seem to belong to the year the car was
made even today everyone she passes
looks and seems to like what they see
she thinks the car looks magnificent add
to that is the 390 horsepower eight
cylinder big-block engine and the cool
sound it makes she says her Chevy's fun
but doesn't such a veteran Corvette like
hers take lots of TLC and tinkering not
really but it does have a gas-guzzling
habit the v8 big-block seven liters
burns lots of fuel fiberglass or not the
car won't even budge without burning
most of the 20 liters it needs to move
100 clicks and the American technology
just isn't up to the searing steady
speeds on today's German autobahns but a
well-maintained Corvette is as
dependable as a VW Rabbit anyway 32 year
old Joey doesn't mind getting her hands
dirty to keep it purring like a kitten
she fixes little things here and there
she's learned how to change the oil and
make cosmetic repairs but she won't get
into the engine itself she likes to
watch but she's afraid she'd end up
doing more harm than good but you
wouldn't mind learning how to do it
someday Joey's thoroughly restored model
is equipped with a rare 4-speed
transmission its prints from zero to 100
in about 6 seconds
but as a policewoman joey is happy to
cruise at the speed limit she doesn't
have to push the envelope in her
Corvette to feel like she's driving a
sports car or any other vintage classic
Joey muses that if she had the money and
a big garage she'd first by a black
chevy chevelle SS and maybe a mustang
fastback and then maybe a car like her
first one a VW Beetle and a triumph like
her father's Joey at her big block
Corvette do go quite well together then
a rival / Joey's affections comes on the
scene but then a Corvette has never
really had to worry about the
competition
and Joey won't even let him behind the
wheel the Corvette has lasted six
generations with a seventh coming up in
autumn this year
you